welcome everybody most of you know I'm
Gloria Duffy president and CEO of the
common law club and I'm going to do the
ritual and gavel us to order here so
welcome to today's meeting of the club
you can find the club on the internet at
commonwealth club org we can see our
videos on youtube sometimes even live
streamed of our programs and catch up
with the club on facebook and twitter so
i'm going to moderate a wonderful
program today with our distinguished
guests Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the US
House of Representatives and the
congressional representative for
California's 12th district right here in
San Francisco now in her second term as
Speaker Nancy Pelosi is the first and
only woman to have held this position
and is considered the most powerful
woman in the political history of the
United States among other yes
a moniker other achievements she was
responsible for the political strategy
and implementation that led to the
Affordable Care Act during President
Obama's presidency she was also in her
seventeenth term as a US Congress woman
representing this great city of San
Francisco she's the author of the 2008
book know your power and indeed she does
when Nancy Pelosi first ran for
political office at the age of 47 she
wasn't new to politics she worked with
her father while he served as mayor of
Baltimore then she worked for Jerry
Brown's presidential campaign and served
as the Democratic Party chair here in
California she developed through those
many years of policy and strategic
leadership qualities that would propel
her to the peak of American politics and
public service I have a personal story
about Nancy's dedication she and I were
on a congressional fact-finding trip in
1985 to Central America we were in
Managua Nicaragua
she was then the finance chair of the
Democratic Senatorial Campaign Committee
we were staying at a hotel in downtown
Managua the rest of us all went out to
dinner on the late side in Central
America we came back at 11:00 or 12:00
at night there were no cell phones at
the time no phones in the rooms we found
Nancy standing in the lobby of the
payphones making calls to her network as
part of her duties as Democratic
Senatorial Campaign Committee Chair this
is truly a dedicated woman and I always
hold that image in mind of that sort of
dark and deserted Lobby late at night in
Managua Nicaragua when I think of Nancy
and her hard work for all of us in the
first 100 days of the hundred and
sixteenth Congress speaker Pelosi and
House Democrat
have worked on therefore the people
agenda passing legislation to clean up
corruption and restore ethics to
Washington DC passed a bipartisan
background checks bill and what many
Democrats call a landmark Paycheck
Fairness bill under Speaker Pelosi House
Democrats are also pursuing a bipartisan
infrastructure deal looking at ways to
expand and protect the right to vote
tackling climate change and lowering
health care costs and prescription drug
prices for all Americans this progress
comes as Democrats welcome the most
diverse caucus in the history of
Congress including more than 100 women
in the same Congress that America will
mark 100 years since women won the right
to vote so today we'll talk about the
state of the country the outlook for
progress despite a divided Congress and
the future of the Democratic Party as
Haiti headed toward the 2020
presidential election please give a warm
welcome to our representative in
Congress and our national political
leader Nancy Pelosi
[Applause]
welcome we have so many things to talk
about and
I think because it's top of mind for
everybody let's start with Robert Muller
statement so most people know the news
he's shut down his office resigned from
the Justice Department he's said that if
he had confidence that no crimes had
been committed he would have reported
that he made a number of other
statements about a president not being
able to be convicted of a crime while in
office tell us I know you've made one
comment already this morning what is
your reaction to his statements this
morning Thank You Gloria for your
question and for the invitation to be
here today it's also wonderful to be at
the Commonwealth Club so many members of
the club and concerned citizens
especially my family my daughter
Christine her husband Peter
father-in-law
Phil Kaufman and Mike our grandson
Octavio and
[Applause]
my son Paul our son Paulus here comes in
here someplace
Paul my phone this is a family affair
for us always we always like to hear
whether word present or viewing or
listening to what is of interest to our
community and I want to salute Gloria
and Duffy she's just so remarkable we're
so blessed why she mentioned what I was
doing while they were having a late
Central America style dinner I'll tell
you what she was doing during the day
and this was so remarkable to all of us
because it was we were there to see what
was happening on Madeline house Russell
Manning maybe a heard of Madeline Hauser
also but she had something called the
Columbia Foundation which sponsored in
California to Central America and this
is history so we went and it was
Democrats and Republicans NGOs it was it
was lovely I mean and when we were there
we were observing what they were
teaching in school and what was
happening was then Ortega still Ortega
and Nicaragua but what's happening in El
Salvador and the rest and as well as
Honduras where some of the Contras were
whatever Gloria was always taking notes
Oh dr. Duncan Gloria was always taking
notes and she was so serious and she was
she had she is as you know an expert on
the Soviet Union Russia and she was
taking notes as to the equipment whether
it was the helicopter the parts that
that airplanes some weapons that
there and she knew their provenance but
we could well we didn't know how they
could have so much stuff there until we
later found out about iran-contra but
she was really getting to the heart of
the matter
right then and there so it was an honor
to travel with her then it's an honor to
be with her today Thank You Gloria so
this morning we all heard a very
patriotic American make his presentation
I had the deepest respect for Special
Counsel well now former Special Counsel
Mahler and what he had to say in his
glory indicated he did say if he saw any
evidence that the president was not what
was innocent he would have let us know
if you had any evidence that the
president was not guilty he would have
let us know but he didn't he didn't and
I think that was very very important
while have the deepest respect for him
and thank him and his team for presented
the presentation of facts that will
further lead us to help us in the
Congress and in the courts this is a
very valuable contribution I am gravely
disappointed in the Justice Department
for their attitude their
misrepresentation of the mulleted report
to begin with they're hiding behind
something that you could never find in
the Constitution that the president is
above the law and their
misrepresentations even under oath by
the Attorney General to the Congress of
the United States so we as we will
continue on our path which was led by
our six chairmen who were magnificent
how major another judiciary Elijah
Cummings of Government Reform and
oversight Maxine Waters Financial
Services Ritchie Neal the president's
taxes ways and means and a like delegate
angle Foreign Affairs all would have a
piece of this last week we had three
victories in the courts one Elijah
Cummings court one the president's
accountant that they have to share the
information to Maxine Waters the
Deutsche Bank decision which is they had
to share the information and three not
related to Russia investigation of that
but related to other promise we have the
president and his view of the
Constitution is that we that court said
that he cannot use Defense Department
funds to build a wall she used that
money to go away Justice Department
under threat of subpoena and the legal
action has decided that they would give
certain important documents to the
committee and that was a victory that
was four days for decisions in five days
very important to advancing our getting
the facts of the American people getting
the truth for the American people where
they will lead us we shall see nothing
is off the table but we do want to make
such a compelling case such an arm cloud
cast case that even the Republican
Senate which at the time seems to be not
an objective jewelry will be changes
the path that we have to take as a
country so you mentioned the victories
in court
you mentioned the various committees
doing their investigations some in
Congress want to go further a
representative Steve Cohen of Tennessee
open a dedicated impeachment inquiry
Judiciary Committee potentially are you
here in committee one I well open a
specific investigation of impeachment
notice as a member of yes because if a
committee has not enough so there are
Democrats in Congress who want to go
further than the existing committee
investigations how do you feel about
that do you think there's a role for an
additional dedicated investigation well
let me just say that I'm very proud of
her our House Democrats they've been
very shall we say conscientious about
how they've reached their decisions and
I think it's like 35 of them out of 238
maybe a 38 of them out of 238 have said
that they wanted to be outspoken on
impeachment and many of them are
reflecting their views as well as those
of their constituents many constituents
want to impeach the president but we
want to do what is right and what gets
it results but gets results
so yes sir our song and the press makes
more of a fuss about the to its 38th and
the 200 who were over half of the
Congress after half of the of the
Democrats and the house sit on one of
these six committees so they're all on
the path of finding more information
just to recall how many people were not
born then but during the that what would
not become impatient but the impeachment
investigation of for tip Nixon but took
months and months about say a Senate
committee that was solely dedicated to a
resurgent impeachment before they then
decided to have articles of impeachment
come from the house which were never
executed because the House and Senate
agreed it was a democratic house and a
Democratic Senate we have a different
scenario now so the case has to be very
compelling to the American people so we
are legislating and we wish the press
would cover more of that Thank You
Gloria for pointing out some of the
bills that we had passed and sent to the
Senate that gun safety was right of
equal pay for equal work
violence against women ad gun safety the
list goes on climate action now the list
goes on but in any event we're
legislating we're investigating and we
are litigating and we're going to as we
go down the path make a decision based
on the strongest possible case to get
the best results for the American people
and the actions taken by the special
counsel today I commend him for the work
that they did to present the facts now
we have to get it unredacted for the
public but nonetheless and for the
Congress by the way they'll say to me I
will show you
not it the American people to know
you're gonna show me and then I'm bound
by classified rules of the house not to
tell anybody you know I don't think so
[Applause]
everybody wants justice
everybody wants the President to be held
accountable in the most serious way and
everybody believes me I'm talking on the
Democratic side that no one is above the
law
especially the President of the United
States come back to the remedies the
2020 election on the run-up to it
there'll be some questions for the
future but let's let's talk about
legislative priorities you mentioned
some of the bills I didn't know this but
I read recently that the first ten HR
numbers are reserved for the speaker's
priorities that is House resolutions or
bill numbers so you have I think nine or
ten on the on the list let's talk about
some of those priorities number one I
understand is the for the people act of
2019 voting rights and ethics what does
that do what's the intent the four that
people act is something that was very
major a priority for us in the campaign
last year our agenda was for the people
one was to lower health care cost by
lowering cost of prescription drugs and
preserving of the pre-existing condition
benefit number two lower health care
costs number to increase paychecks by
building infrastructure of American
agreeing resilient way number three was
clean government cleaner government
lower health care costs bigger paychecks
cleaner government and this was
legislation set out to address
the fact that big dark money has too
much of the role and decision-making in
Washington DC and sometimes people say
to me well I understand the healthcare
thing I understand the building
infrastructure and paychecks but why is
HR 1 important well its central these
cabinets everything else gives people
confidence that a big dark money from
the fossil fuel industry we're not
interfering with our climate crisis and
our agenda to address it big dark money
from the gun lobbyists
were not in the play we might be able to
pass in the Senate which we've already
passed and a half Gun Violence
Prevention Act the list goes on and so
was central central to the integrity of
people voting in Congress I'm not saying
that everybody is painting every we want
the same brush but what I am saying is
right now you see the president in a
denial of science on climate how could
that be how could that be in addition to
that we won this election this is not
politics as a civics we won this
election in the most gerrymandered voter
suppressed political arena you could
possibly imagine and that isn't the way
it should be we were able to win in
spite of the fact that they suppress the
vote that chairman of the district they
had politicians choosing their
constituents instead of constituents
choosing their politicians and
nonetheless was still won because we
leapfrog we let frogs that what it would
be
over all of that with HR one part of HR
1 and central to it is John Lewis's
piece which is about ending border
suppression we can go more into that if
you wish and the other piece of it is to
pass a Voting Rights Act and that is in
Asia 1 but it's also taking a literally
pass HR 1 but we need to do more on HR
for the boat passing Voting Rights Act
because we have to have again ironclad
case in the court so that they don't
overturn as the Supreme Court did in my
view only the Voting Rights Act that was
became on 2007 that recent so HR 1 is
it's about just not a precious breath of
fresh air a gust of a wind coming
through DC to make the change that must
be changed for the good of the people to
increase the impact of love brass and
it's people of small donors and decrease
the role of big dark money and politics
so HR 2 infrastructure plans well this
is the bill that we're trying for
together with the President and we have
but anyway I still feel optimistically
percent of the time that I have had a
conversation in person or by phone with
the president he has mentioned he wants
to do infrastructure and I think he
still does does he want to do it enough
to not be in a huff over my saying these
involved in a cover-up well we'll see
but this is not for the feint apart and
you wouldn't want to do it or you don't
want to do it you shouldn't be offended
by somebody speaking truth about your
actions
existential and my wife I'm a doctor
dotty if I may madam president
I like that sound man the thing that
breaks my heart is when they introduced
me is the highest ranking 119 you know
it wasn't supposed to be this way a
woman president
anyway that may sound
let me just place this idea this
infrastructure in a larger perspective I
believe that we have three imperatives
that we must address in our nation and
and our for the people agenda as part of
that but it's bigger even than that
and one of them one of them is the
essential threat to our planet that the
crime climate crisis poses as this
administration and my friends on the
other side of the aisle whether because
I'm cozy with the fossil fuel industry
or whatever it is are in denial about
the science this is a challenge to the
planet of this generation and young
people understand it better than even
the President of the United States so
that's one the other and one of the
others is the acidity the acidity of
income disparity in our country this is
wrong that the fact that CEOs can make
three four hundred times as much as
their employees when used to be maybe 40
years ago only 30 40 times as much but
now in a two-week period a CEO might
make as much as a employee makes in ten
years it's just wrong and it's not good
for our economy because we need to have
a strong middle class which is the
backbone of our economy and which is if
it would consumer confidence it is good
for the economy
so disparity of income climate crisis
all served by building the
infrastructure of America raising
paychecks the the amount of paychecks
and
as doing it an agreeing resilience away
and the third in a pair that one
imperative dress the climate crisis
second imperative a disparity in income
in our country third despair this
birther issue cleaner government which
makes the other two possible so if we
channel our energies and our legislative
priorities in a way that advances those
causes addresses those priorities it
will be not only good for our economy
and our society will be good for our our
democracy and I want us to do and I say
this to members and sometimes while you
tell me if you agree or not I want to do
it in a way the priorities that we have
the one through ten here are those that
haven't very broad support in the public
very broad support gun safety equal pay
for equal work violence against women
we've named some of gun violence
prevention and the rest kind of action
now the Equality Act ending
discrimination against LGBTQ community
these issues have broad support in the
power and so that's where we want to go
is to make progress in the place where
we had the most unity
I think our founders were brilliant
thank God
a constitution of mandible could ever be
expanding freedom but they also gave us
guidance they said a pluribus unum from
anyone they could imagine how many we
would be different we'd be from each
other but they knew that we had a strive
for oneness their country is one rather
than to divide but to unite and and I
said we hope to do and all of our
actions is to remember that guidance
which is very important they're out
there to just pick a fight to pick a
fight or out there to get results to
improve the lives of America's working
families and for the children so a small
plug for the Commonwealth Club we don't
lobby or take positions but for eleven
years we've had a project called climate
one which educates and promotes debate
and learning about climate change so
we're very active and trying to spread
awareness of the science and so on there
are a couple of different thank you for
that it's the courts and it's about
public health clean air clean water food
safety Public Health
it's about jobs jobs jobs jobs green
technology America being preeminent in
the world Green's oh no it's about our
national security a national security
effort experts tell us all the time that
the climate issues whether it's rising
sea levels encroachment of deserts that
a drought famine all the rest will cause
migrations which can sometimes lead to
conflict so it's a security issue and
then also it's a moral issue if you
believe as I do that this is God's
creation we have a moral responsibility
to be good stewards and if you don't
even share that with a religious
approach we all know that we have a
responsibility to our to future
generations to pass on this planet and
respond
away so we had every motivation whether
it's security jobs health morality to do
what you have taken the lead or and I
think that come up kind of well and I
thank you for your leadership there are
a couple of different strategies in
Congress now and on climate change so
there's the green new deal which some
members are sponsoring legislation to
support and then there is the
legislation to shore up the Paris
climate summit could you talk about
where you fall among these different
strategies and why not the green new
deal which is a bit more comprehensive
or radical if in fact this is the
existential threat
well the we new deal is a wonderful
aspirational statement and that's what
it is
it's not legislation it's an
aspirational statement and it's a
wonderful thing to attract attention and
galvanize support but it's not a
legislation so we still have to and
that's why I appointed a Select
Committee on climate headed by Cathy
castor who's wonderful from Florida she
she is on the Energy and Commerce
Committee but mastered all of this - and
actually three freshmen and I put three
freshmen on the committee as well
- to address what the best legislation
is for us to go for in addition to what
we passed HR
which is climate action now to reinforce
our involvement with the Paris Accord
and to ask the president what he's but
his suggestions are but it's not that
the legislation is legislation as
advocacy is advocacy so some of those
things will be included some of them had
nothing to do directly with climate they
have to do with income and this or that
again all of this is related but in
terms of what we put forth for the
climate crisis initiative that will be
developed and not have tasked every
committee of Congress whether it's
defense committee whether it's energy
and commerce and Natural Resources some
of them are the national domain of
climate but others like Defense
Department Defense Department uses more
energy and can be more shall we say
climate conscious than any of the
department's it makes a big difference
but event of them all the Ways and Means
Committee in terms of how we would
finance how a little forth
Appropriations Committee what
initiatives we can take but you have to
know let me just put this in this
context when I will speaker the first
time my flagship is she was climate
climate and energy independence working
with President Bush who didn't he was a
climate denier but he understood that we
hadn't cleaned up the air and so we
passed the biggest energy bill in the
history of our country
energy bill 2007 it was like taking tens
of millions of cars off the road when we
raise the cafe standards the
mission standards did many other things
with a strong commitment for for
renewables than he signed the bill he
wanted and he wanted nuclear I wanted
renewables he signed the bill and then
it came Japan and said not but just
happened on the nuclear side but we got
what we wanted on the Renewable side so
so this has been a priority for us for a
while and then when we lost the majority
the supplemented much of it unraveled we
had a green the capital band there that
you know that was some it was important
it was symbolic but nonetheless they
undid it anyway and went back to this
denials and now are in the majority
pretty soon we'll have a president who
will recognize the importance of the
climate crisis and had policies that
support that but until we do we have to
keep making this case with the American
people about that's a ramification of
Elections what happens on the climate
issue so so again so we review
everything on the table what some of the
things that are contained in the green
new deal are the things that we've all
been advocating for a while some are
groundbreaking some again
not relate to climate directly but are
important to be considered in their own
context but we will we will this is an
imperative it is not an issue it's not a
deal it is a value it is again an
imperative that it get be done but we
wanted to get done in a way that unifies
people our friends and labour Havanese
with some aspects other green new deal
there's no reason why we can't come to
more unit and they had been there for us
we've had the blue green Alliance blue
and green alliance with them for a while
on this so we can bring people together
but they all have to be at the table as
we shape the consensus that is the
boldest toughest common denominator and
not any weakening of the result you're
wearing a pin today last a couple of
weeks ago Madeleine Albright was with us
and we always ask her what does her pin
signify because she wears a different
pin every day you're wearing a very
important pin oh it is bad
well Madeleine Albright has a beautiful
array of pins real pants real and she
always said when she would come to
testify read my ten
is that the environment the butterflies
are beautiful and they've been doing
museum quality and on display mine is
simply the mace the symbol of power of
the Speaker of the House and
and planet Congress opens you know they
enter with the mace all rise with the
mace and every now that I like to wear
that calm so people can see
[Music]
you're my bosses I want you to see the
job let's talk about your leadership
Jerry Brown was with us recently and we
talked a little bit about
accomplishments after the age of say 70
he talked a little bit about what he
learned in his first term as governor
his first round as governor and how he
applied those in his second round as
governor so what are you what have you
accomplished and what have you learned
over time there's been this debate of
course about Dianne Feinstein and
chashni retire and all of that I've
noticed that there's a lot of
accomplishment by our leaders in their
70s do I consider this a rude question
it's not meant to be 76 the here's the
thing one thing that Jerry Brown said to
me I became speaker again he said
there's nothing as liberating as term
limits
and that's the lesson in fact don't you
think because at a certain point when
you have your experience you know you
know you know your look I think from my
standpoint one of the things that held
me in good stead when I became leader to
begin with first of all just support in
contact I had never intended to run for
Congress never that was abrupt for any
public office you said I'd worked with
my father I was a little girl I witness
public service and and when I was in
first grade II became when I was born he
was in Congress when I became was in
first grade he became the mayor of
Baltimore Thomas Golisano when I went to
college of my whole freshman year coffee
was still the mayor of Baltimore it was
there anyone we knew is that public
service is a noble calling doesn't mean
you run for office or even just engaging
campaigns but to be involved civically
and that it placed a big value on that
and that's part of what I learned there
but I also learn how to count votes and
that's an important thing
so they learned what I say to candidates
all the time know your why why are you
running what is your vision show us what
do you know about it your knowledge how
do you expect to accomplish something
but is your strategic thinking your
vision your knowledge your strategic
thinking most important thing though is
how do you connect hard to hawk this is
all here the rest of it heart to heart
with the voters so that you know they
know that you care about their crazy
dreams their aspirations and their
apprehensions and that's really what is
important and that's kind of what you
thought I mean I never intended to run
for Congress first of all but then I
never intended join for leadership until
people encouraged me to do so but in the
mean time I was due I dug deeply into my
work on Appropriations
and when intelligence and so I knew knew
I knew my subjects and so I could
negotiate from knowledge and strength
and to promote a vision and they said
that when I became a leader the
experience I had was not a disadvantage
because time had passed as I was gaining
it but it was an advantage and now so
when you're doing the job that I'm doing
is you really have to know again the
vision that we build as a consensus in
our caucus our goals our vision our wine
the knowledge we bring to the discussion
to make good judgments about the past
were on strategic thinking about getting
it done but then it is a question of
courage courage every you know
everybody's commitment you know their
convictions who has the courage to make
the votes because they're not always
popular at home and
is what experience teaches you as well
to be very very respectful of what
motivates people to vote one way or
another and to make a judgment as you
establish priorities of that what is
really going to produce the result or
what's just going to be a conversation
because you want results for the
American people
so I would say that in the passage of
time that experienced as Jerry said he
says said she brought a lot where he
used to say and when when he was running
for governor the first time you know
youth we need youth we knew the men when
he ran in a second time twenty men years
later there's no substitute for
experience
so I would say that but the main thing
that I love so much about it is to be
able to encourage other people that take
responsibilities to be clear about their
vision to know what they're talking
about to understand how they can have a
plan for success and many members of
cons of course come flocking in with all
of this but to give them the opportunity
for example
just going back to Watergate for a
moment when that class came in the
Watergate babies it was transformative
was a huge class and transformative
similar to the classic we had now not
one of those freshmen that came in that
year had a gavel was a chair of a
subcommittee not one of them and in the
first year in this Congress with our
transformative new diverse class 18
freshmen our chairs of subcommittees
and their leadership is Magnifico
example one of the first Native American
women ever to serve in the Congress and
to in this class for the first two Deb
Hollen she is the chair of the
subcommittee of the Natural Resources
Committee on public lands imagine so try
to give them guidance about committee
selection mr. net and some who don't
have gavels on committees that are very
strong for their districts so we made
sure that people got what they wanted
when they came and got and back to plays
leadership roles and that's one of the
advantages that I have and just kind of
you may not realize how important this
is to you but think about it and in a
new fresh way when I'm saying that to to
the bread think about this in this way
and nothing no talk to your folks about
it let me know but I think this would be
a good path and some of them knew in
their own they didn't need any guidance
that's for sure
but did you said we were diverse cut 60%
of our class of our freshmen no 60% of
the House Democrats are women people of
color LGBTQ
saying spirit or as chairs of committees
and I don't you see did the table a seat
at the head of the table so so I think
that whatever it means to me I think
what it means to my colleagues if they
trust my judgment and I consider that an
advantage for our caucus and I have
nothing but respect for our elder
stateswoman Diane Diane senior in the
South seniority is everything they just
want those committees and hold the bend
and they were like we want something
fresh and new wait a minute with
seniority goes power in the Senate of
the United States and she has great
power in the Senate of the United States
immigration
Donald Trump has announced a merit-based
immigration plan you've said some things
about this publicly tell us what you
think about this how should we be
proceeding be much all that done on top
we talk about Ronald Reagan instead okay
this is what Ronald Reagan said this is
the last speech I would make as
president of the United States the FAQ
at your attention mom Reagan this is
Siletz and I wanted to communicate a
message the country I love he wouldn't
want to say I talked about the Statue of
Liberty and what it meant as a beacon of
hope to the world and what it meant to
people coming to our country or people
who had come but saw the Statue of
Liberty first she said our parents our
grandparents our ancestors anyway I want
to say that in effect and I want you to
look it up because it's much more poetic
than what I'm going to say but this is
the essence the vital force of America's
preeminence in the world is every new
generation of newcomers who come to our
country and when America fails to
recognize that America will fail to be
preeminent in the world we cannot close
the door to immigrants to our country if
we do so we will fail to be preeminent
mom Reagan Ronald Reagan President
Reagan President Bush President Clinton
President Bush President Barack Obama
all subscribed to the vitality the
jubilation reinvigoration of America of
that immigration is to our country hopes
dreams aspirations courage optimism
determination to make the future better
all-american traits these newcomers make
America more American until the 45th
President of the United States now do we
need to have comprehensive immigration
reform I heart ascend bill that
the Senate then Republican in the house
would not bring up a few years ago
unfortunately it was a lot of
compromises
I didn't mother to death but I loved
enough and but they just would not give
us a vote on it we have to get to that
place when the president says merit
turned it upside down that means make
America white again
I had people leave just go back and
we'll just let in who we like I don't
know if Merrick accounted for when his
wife's death but he calls that chain
migration when she wants to get rid of
cell reunification instead of call it
Mary should we attach a green card to
the diploma of so many scientists and
engineers and all the rest and graduate
students who trained in the u.s. so that
they can stay here of course but that's
not the point the point is that the
president does not share the view of
even Ronald Reagan and two bushes in
recent history as to the value of the
vitality of immigrants to our country so
there's an audience question about
abortion rights and there's a sense that
some of the state legislation going on
is gradually removing some of them
anyway protected rights so in that
context the question is how can we find
a get or preserve abortion rights for
all American women this is really a
tragedy what is but it's happening in
terms of Alabama I was in Ohio recent
they have a laws in Missouri recently
they've it's it's it's heartbreaking
because it's so disrespectful of women
and women's right to choose and it goes
along with we don't want equal pay for
equal work we know all those kinds of
things as well it's a sign of disrespect
but it's one that is as brutal the early
wait is the law of the land it should be
upheld
instead of being undermined I don't want
to be a fear monger but I do think we
have to take drastic action by that I
mean full-blown Mobility mobilization
every place my daughter Christine
participated in one is it worth 400 you
had in one day right after Alabama that
all over the country on this this is
absolutely wrong but just if you promise
not to tell anybody I told you this
got to be President of the United States
three years ago from this June the
president said I was choose my justices
from this list these were all anti roe v
wade judges just about two weeks ago
this within the past few weeks the
Senate approved some judges one of them
said that plan a family planning caused
cancer another one said Planned
Parenthood killed 170,000 people in
recent time another one said that family
planning undermined the religious off
the religious nature of our country so
understand that this isn't about just
abortion it's about family planning it's
a bit of a woman's right to choose the
size and timing of her family with her
own family our own God our own dollars
and the rest so this is understand it's
for 25 years
my first 25 years old I kept saying
people it's about family planning I
understand this they use abortion as
their but because they see division
there and they've described in horrible
ways but but this is also bad family
planning
do you understood that they they believe
that all coming together should be about
conceiving a child so marriage equality
and moving weight are both of their
targets in that regard and it's really
so very very sad so we just have to be
active we don't agonize we organize and
we have to organize all over the country
so that people
understand that this is not the right
thing do this the hypocrisy of it all
that they would say no exception for
rape and incest but something like that
happen in their family do you think they
would not avail themselves of other
choices and that for them to say a
doctor who performs such a thing such a
procedure would go to jail for 99 years
or something like that this is not real
now I hear I had to fight with them all
the time over the years because I
thought my husband Paul and I were
blessed to have five children and we had
five children when we brought Alexander
our youngest Johnson the hospital
our oldest Nancy Graham was turning six
at that week so I know the program
and that's great for us but why should
that be something that someone else
should subscribe to so when we had this
debate on the floor some years ago and I
was it just it just steams me because
it's not their business and they don't
know what they're talking about I don't
think they need to lessen the burdens of
the house or having this back and forth
and I say this as an ardent practicing
devout Catholic I mean this is not right
you know it's just nothing anyway on the
floors of the house one of them Dunham
said Nancy Pelosi think she knows more
about having babies than the Pope
we probably would to imagine imagine if
you would just see it just see this the
line of the men standing up in the
chamber signing on for these anti-choice
discharge petition that they have now
they just still they just don't get it
but you know what we again don't agonize
organized we just I have to understand
that elections have ramifications and
without the support of the Advanta local
community who might have work with on
immigration they're wonderful
immigration many of them do believe this
is God's creation we have to protect our
planet but on this subject he is
forgiven and when I say to them you know
you care about an immigration and he's
taking babies and the arms of their
mothers he's separating families how can
you how can you look the otherwise
during the best he can really
that's the best you can well maybe it is
but that's certainly not good enough to
humanity it is it is what got him there
and that's where he is that's what bro
moved to the dance that's where he is
and he's appointing those judges who
will follow that course of action and
that's most unfortunate so this next
year and a half made go by quickly and
everybody being in good health and so
we'll see what happens next book but we
really do have to fight in each of these
states and then a round Planned
Parenthood and so many of the other
organizations had been working
effectively in different states to try
to offset some of the assaults on the
judgement of women the judgment of women
and their families and then to I mean
families is about family but this is
this is really tragic because of what it
could lead to in those communities and
by the way did we all agree it harms
poor people more than other people and
their justice everyone so there are
these many issues and there's a question
of the upcoming presidential election
there's a question from an audience
member setting aside the merits of a
particular candidate or another what do
you think is the optimal strategy for
winning the presidential election
focusing on swing voters Democratic
voters or what you want to holla ticks
yes
I thought we were in some kind of a
nonprofit arena hero which restraining
myself
from specific candidates let me just say
thank you to all of the candidates who
are going to put themselves on the line
into the arena to subject themselves to
whatever criticism and the rest this is
not for the faint of heart to go out
there and put yourself forward so for
that I thank them all any one of them
would be a better president I do believe
I do believe that what I've said earlier
show your vision
why show your knowledge what do you know
about it so that people respect your
judgment strategic thinking okay now all
of them have that I think they've been
brilliant who connects that's where the
election will who connects to the heart
of heart with the American people and I
think that will make a difference and as
the field if it does we know it's down
before the convention and I think it
probably will but it is a message that
is wonderful for me and San Francisco is
something that we have to incorporate
into a more mainstream message across
the country it doesn't mean that we
lessen our intensity or anything it just
means we're we have the most consensus
to win that's how we won last year
respecting but again my San Francisco
message is a big winner here that it may
not necessarily be a big winner other
places but
raising the minimum wage health care for
all Americans protecting our environment
all the things that are something that
we would all be zhilie agree with them
to do so in the most aggressive way our
mainstream messages across the country
so we'll just see who can I always just
say who connects because we've had great
candidates before who had all the vision
all the knowledge of judgment all the
strategic thinking that not necessarily
always connect so so look out for the
emotional connection in addition to the
rest of it but aren't we proud of them
they're also courageous not only tasting
it is not for the faint of heart
and I'll just tell you myself people ask
me how you take all the hits target
I said that's their problem if I were
not effective I wouldn't be an object of
their
[Music]
right now there is a false video that
the Republicans are putting out on
Facebook now this is self-serving with
me to say but I say it because I don't
want other women say to me sometimes I
would run but I couldn't subject my
family to what you go through so what we
need you to run so you know we have to
get past that
but when a something like facebook says
I know this is false but it's a lie but
we're showing it anyway well to me it
says two things one that they promised I
was giving them the benefit of the doubt
on Russia but clearly they I thought it
was unwitting but clearly they wittingly
were accomplices and enablers of false
information to go across baseball at you
if you attend whether it's a woman or
whatever but I'm trying to get more
women people of color young people to
run and then to if you were going to go
out there why would you subject yourself
to that too bad and that's what
disappoints me it's like I don't care I
can take it
experience no but I can I can handle it
all but it has the Excalibur and being
Speaker of the House but these other
people are new to the arena and we want
and they're fabulous people and they
have talent and courage and the rest and
they have options well if I could do
that or I think they do this or that I
said well we don't want people with at
all
that's what I wanted to run for Congress
because you could also do this or that
and so so that negative in the arena you
know as I say in the arena you have to
be ready to take a punch but you have to
be ready to throw on to as I said for
the children it is to women though
really know your power know how
important it is to have many more women
we have a hundred and six in the House
of Representatives 91 or Democrats
because we made a decision to elect
women every committee so it's the
uniqueness is it different yeah it's
different and different is important
different view at the table so when
you're thinking about it think about how
needed you are and I have no doubt this
is an absolute fact you might consider
the rest opinion this isn't that exact
that if we lower the role decrease of
all of money in politics and increase
the level of civility and politics when
many more women and minorities and young
people taking your chance and running
for office so the club this year next
year is doing some concentrated
programming on mental health and mental
illness we're collaborating with the
Pritzker family fund and he's
we had a great talk a couple weeks ago
by the actress Glenn Close who's working
two distinct my ties mental illness some
of the candidates presidential
candidates are surfacing interesting
ideas and one of them is Seth Moulton
member of Congress he's made a proposal
for comprehensive mental health
legislation that would improve benefits
for veterans and screen veterans I think
this is coming to some extent out of
concern about mass shootings it's on a
screen veterans of checkup mental health
checkups also screen schoolchildren
increase the Pentagon budget form I'm
not familiar with his legislation but
lessen lives the issue to the mental
health issue yes we did pass legislation
for mental health parity in it is it is
a health issue it is a physical health
issue you know it's mental but it is it
is to be treated because it has physical
aspects to it we have that then we have
been part of that into the Affordable
Care Act but what we really need in
addition to that and the thank you for
mentioning and said there's a better
that the part of that the veterans right
now and this is something we spend a lot
of time with honoring our veterans that
we say on the battlefield we notice that
the military is no soldier define behind
when they come home we need to know a
veteran behind when they come home if
every mental health professional who is
in school right now when upon graduation
every one of them went to to address
veterans mental health
we would still not have enough and
there'd be nobody for anybody else so we
have to enable many more people to be
engaged whether we're helping with their
student loan debt and all the rest of
that to go down this path but we do need
the health care professionals the
beautiful thing about our vets is that
maybe a third of them have admitted to a
mental health other veterans returning
vets dimensional health challenges and
that's a big thing because it had been a
stigma before and now at least a third
and so that maybe mean more are
challenged in that way
PTSD a big challenge to the families the
caregivers of these vets and the rest
but with all the focus we have on this
it's not just the vets it's everybody in
our community and while it is an issue
that relates to Mesmer most people
ninety-nine something something percent
of people with mental illness are not
violent people in our country so we
cannot kind of say but for that we
wouldn't have these mass murders but but
it is it is an initiative and we cannot
let those who want to avoid the gun
violence prevention the registering had
not registering the guns but to didn't
have he bought a sign up of for
background sure the background checks
and the rest of that we can't have
people say well we don't really need
that it's just a
mental health issue no but isn't just a
minute old house they should gun
shouldn't be in the hands of certain
people some of them may have a mental
challenge but the mental health argument
is not an argument against background
check legislation so this is this is
deadly serious in terms of how we engage
ourselves in conflict and send our
people to war how we treat them when
they come home how we recognize that in
families have been made nothing to do
with veterans that we have these
challenges Glenn Close has a family
situation she visited me recently in DC
about these issues and again removing
the stigma it is very important but
having the funding is also very very
even more important to do the
investments that we need in the
resources whether it's health care
professionals or the diagnoses that are
important early enough on but I
appreciate your question about the
mental health pretty large
there are many proposals in the Congress
but all of them will have to come
through as we suggest all the health
proposals whether it's Medicare for all
whether it's healthcare for all but
they're all different proposals on the
table just to have health care for all
Americans and that means mental health
it isn't even a separate category I
didn't you I said it isn't even a
separate category but it has been
neglected so we want to treat it in a
more important way
the manifestations of it in a more
important way but all that comes back to
building the infrastructure of America
as we and building the human
infrastructure in America health care
education investments in the future for
our country so that we to build our
country we have a workforce development
to do it to have our families succeed
they know that they will be able to have
financial stability and the biggest
challenge to that is healthcare
healthcare costs so all of it all of it
is is connected and that's why the
imperative of any of the disparity
Chaleff facing the challenge of the
common crisis but the door to it all
opening the door to all of it is
lowering the role of big dark money and
politics I thank you Commonwealth club
for being a venue for the discussion of
ideas in a way that as I said about
founders we are one whatever our
differences we respect each other in the
discussion we don't question motivation
except to say let's share our vision for
a country where we liberty justice how
about our how about island with this how
bout our founders life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness as part of our
national purpose that pursuit means that
we have to work together to be one
Commonwealth Club is a force for all of
that thank you
thank you to Nancy Pelosi Speaker of the
US House of Representatives for being
here and for your service
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]